[Musique]
selon nos informations l'hypothèse d'un
confinement le week end en ile-de-france
est écarté tous les leviers autre que
leur confinement sont prioritaires
affirme ainsi un ministre
on fait du bragg matic on fait du sur
mesure explique l'entourage du président
le pas de calais et ses plages la seine
saint denis et sa concentration urbaine
de département ou dans les chiffres
le coc vide sévit de façon comparable ce
soir pourtant le premier ministre
devrait annoncer que seul le pas de
calais sera confiné le week end
ce que je trouve très drôle c'est que
c'est peut-être la deuxième chaîne
d'information vous êtes la première
avant l'elysée parce que vous donner les
informations que l'elysée donnera ce
soir que le premier nice donnera ce soir
dire la veille on nous dit demain le
premier ministre nous dira que analyse
des derniers chiffres et les retours des
échanges avec les élus de ces
territoires
me conduisent à étendre le dispositif de
confinement le week-end à l'ensemble du
département du pas de calais dans les
autres départements à risque
les évolutions observées ne justifie pas
de prendre à ce stade des mesures
équivalentes ont les mêmes taux
d'incidence que certains départements
d'ile-de-france et nous impose le
confinement dans le pas de calais alors
que au motif que sa déplairait aux
populations on n'impose pas le même
profil en ile-de-france pour que est
franchement c'est ce que je ne comprends
pas ce soir c'est la stupéfaction et la
compréhension sont le département du pas
de calais ont huit mois vaccinés on est
moins vaccinées dans le département du
vaccin et qu'ailleurs on est sous
équipée sous dosés il ya une
surmortalité liée à la situation
sanitaire de notre population est
aujourd'hui les français sont fatigués
d'un d'une nuit qui n'en finit pas mais
au delà de donner cet horizon il faut se
donner surtout les moyens de sortir de
ce tunnel
c'est à dire vacciner beaucoup plus il
faut confiné là où il faut confiné il
faut du couvre-feu
là où c'est nécessaire mais aussi libéré
et qu'on puisse faire des concerts qu'on
puisse faire des allées au cinéma qu'on
puisse aller au théâtre qu'on puisse
aller dans certains restaurants fait que
toutes ces choses à soi penser
concrètement et ça n'est pas le cas
parce que je crois qu'il décide tout
seul et que sa grande jouissance c'est
de pouvoir dire
ce sera ça appuie de dire quelques
heures après ce sera aussi sa ses
prochains week-ends même si vous n'y est
pas contraint rester le plus possible
chez vous limitez ce qu'on appelle vos
interactions sociales
si vous avez des symptômes olivier
veyrat on vous l'a dit testez-vous est
isolé vous sans aucun délai nous devons
tenir ensemble
la justice reconnaît enfin mon innocence
les mots à l'instant d'edouard balladur
l'ancien premier ministre vient en effet
d'être relaxé dans la sphère qui
concerne le financement illégal de sa
campagne présidentielle de 1995
ainsi en a décidé la cour de justice de
la république françois léotard ministre
de la défense à l'époque a été lui
condamné à deux ans de prison avec
sursis 100 mille euros damende déjà sur
une victoire du rassemblement national
qui est malheureusement devenue selon
elle une très forte probabilité je ne
veux pas de l'extrême droite dans notre
pays c'est le point de vue d'anne
hidalgo qui ajoute jusqu'à l'été
beaucoup de déplacements et à l'automne
on aura peut-être des choses à se dire
je veux prendre ce temps là réellement
et quant à l'appel à la haine ce qui
avait été mis en avant particulièrement
c'était une action qu'ils avaient en
fait d'occupation du toit du chantier de
la mosquée poitiers en 2012 lors du
lancement de génération identitaire
action pour laquelle nous n'avons eu
aucune condamnation également donc les
fondements juridiques déjà en tant que
tels sont assez bancale et d'ailleurs ça
a été relevé par de très nombreux
observateurs interdit de parole sur
france culture on m'a interdit de parole
pour le miler si populaire là pour le
coup je prêche pas pour ma part moi je
dis juste que quand on n'est pas
d'accord avec quelqu'un on débat mais on
ne dit pas je ferme qu'est ce qu'on
imagine de deux générations identitaire
y aura plus générations d'auditeurs et
veilleront se reconstituer c'est le
principe des ligues dissoutes
mais après s'être reposé regardez il ya
commencé à voir le feu
et puis starship a explosé au sol
quelques minutes plus tard quand ça
fonctionne c'est formidable
space x mais aucune explication n'a donc
été fournie dans l'immédiat